es la última catástrofe para un pueblo
azotado por más de 11 años de guerra
oímos sus voces siguen vivos pero no hay
forma de sacarlos no hay nadie que los
rescate no hay maquinaria hacemos un
llamamiento a todos los países hacemos
un llamamiento a la humanidad los
edificios del noroeste de Siria
controlado por la oposición se
derrumbaron esta vez por los brutales
terremotos pero sus habitantes la
mayoría desplazados internos de otras
regiones del país llevan más de una
década Sobreviviendo al estruendo de las
bombas y ataques aéreos del régimen
autoritario de bachar al azar y su
Aliado Rusia la guerra debilitó las
precarias infraestructuras también las
sanitarias magnificando la tragedia por
los sismos millones ya se han visto
obligados a oír por la guerra en la
región más amplia y ahora muchos serán
desplazados por este desastre en medio
de la tormenta de invierno y una crisis
del costo de vida sin precedentes es
vital que los sirios no se vean
obligados a enfrentar en las
consecuencias por su cuenta precisamente
son los cascos blancos un equipo de
protección civil durante la época más
intensa del conflicto los que llevan
años sacando de los escombros a la
población sin ningún apoyo Estatal el
91% de los 4,1 millones de residentes de
la región sobreviven gracias a la ayuda
humanitaria cuyo ingreso depende de la
aprobación cada seis meses el consejo de
seguridad de la ONU para mantener o no
abierto el cruce fronterizo con Turquía
y cuya financiación no incluye a los
desastres naturales
necesitamos que la comunidad
internacional haga algo que nos ayude
que nos apoye El noroeste de Siria es
ahora una zona catastrófica ciudades
bajo el control del régimen como alepo
la taquia ojama también reportaron
graves daños y decenas de muertos por el
terremoto mientras El dictador alasad no
ha emitido un mensaje de condolencias
que da esperar ahora Cómo será la
entrada de ayuda humanitaria Siria
puesto que las relaciones diplomáticas
entre el régimen y occidente están
suspendidas desde el inicio de la guerra
en 2011